foreign
bribery Bob Menendez isn't going down
without a fight the New Jersey Democrat
Senator is defiant and resisting calls
to step down after getting indicted on
federal corruption charges the feds
found nearly half a million dollars in
cash stuffed into jackets embroidered
with his name and the U.S Senate seal as
well as a hundred grand worth of gold
bars in his home Menendez is accused of
taking bribes in an attempt to benefit
the government of Egypt but Senator gold
Barr vows that in the end he'll be
exonerated
the allegations leveled against me are
just that
allegations not only will I be
exonerated
but I still will be the New Jersey's
senior senator to those who have rushed
to judgment you have done so based on a
limited set of facts framed by the
prosecution to be as salacious as
possible
remember
prosecutors get it wrong Sometimes some
of the people calling from my
resignation for political reasons say I
have lost the trust to the people of New
Jersey
that couldn't be more wrong the case
against Menendez may be tough to beat
given that the wads of cash found at his
house had the Fingerprints of one of his
co-conspirators on it the Bob says never
mind that hoarding half a million is all
part of his Cuban heritage
for 30 years I have withdrawn thousands
of dollars in cash from my personal
savings account
which I have kept for emergencies and
because of the history of my family
facing confiscation in Cuba now this may
seem old-fashioned but these were monies
drawn from my personal savings account
based on the income that I have lawfully
derived over those 30 years
Democrats are split on what to do about
Menendez some say he's got to go but the
white house isn't taken aside
this is a serious matter we
[Music]
we believe the senator stepping down
from his chairmanship was the right
thing to do obviously the right thing to
do as it relates to anything else any
decision that he has to make that's
certainly going to be up to him and the
Senate leadership to decide but of
course we see this as a serious matter
and I'm just going to leave it there for
now
so judge uh he was the chair of the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee who
was chair before that or not before that
but in the past Joe Biden it seems like
this is how you get the bribes as you
get on the Foreign Relations Committee
because that puts you into contact with
people who can give you money I don't
know why you would be suggesting that
this is a Democrat thing it makes no
sense I mean just because Menendez got a
Mercedes and Hunter Biden got a Porsche
just because Menendez has allegedly
gotten cash and Hunter Biden got cash
just because when Menendez wanted to
have a meeting at the Vice President Joe
Biden's house at the Naval Observatory
he doesn't call the vice president he
doesn't even call Hunter I mean he
doesn't call anyone other than Hunter
Biden to have a dinner and a luncheon at
the vice president's house okay let's
talk about this case number one why
would Menendez who was not acquitted
there was a hung jury in the last trial
why would this guy go anywhere near the
edge of of corruption knowing that the
feds don't take kindly to a case where
they don't get a conviction stupid
number one number two doing a press
conference where you literally locked
yourself into statements every one of
which will be used against him at a
trial I.E you know I took the money out
of the bank because my family may need
it in Cuba well wait a minute Bob did
you give it to your driver or your
neighbor to hold it is that why his
fingerprints and DNA are on the envelope
dumb now in in The Amazing part he
wasn't willing to give Donald Trump the
benefit of the doubt this is two months
before the Mueller report came out he
said we need to know for sure whether
Donald Trump is a Putin puppet and he
goes on and on now we know the Durham
report Donald Trump the whole thing was
made up by Hillary Clinton now is it
people in New Jersey haven't heard
rumors for years about this guy he has
been in public life since 1986 when he
was the mayor of Union New Jersey you
want to tell me how someone who's been
in public life for almost four decades
has a half a million dollars in cash
that he takes out just in case he needs
to send it to Cuba and there's a whole
other thing he is now not right now he's
no longer chair of the Foreign Relations
Comm committee uh he stepped down from
that but you know the the day after he
returns from Egypt and I want to say
something that's in his favor the the
accusation is not that he gave
classified information it said he gave
sensitive non-public information we got
to find out what that is but in the end
the guy comes home from Egypt the next
day and he Googles how much is a brick
of gold worth it's like a murderer
Googling how long does it take for the
body to decompose Paul William Devane
he knows the answer to that question a
lot of other questions too Jesse so he
stuffed this money in his jacket pocket
in the in the closet which is what you
do with cigarettes so your wife can't
find them do you buy his reason for
having all that cash because you never
know when emergency might strike so he
says he's Cuban and all Cubans keep cash
sewn into their windbreakers because you
know the government can seize it at any
moment we googled them because that's
what we do and we found out he was born
in the United States
parents it's parents are Cuban but his
parents in 1954 had him in the United
States they didn't have money seized by
Castro so this whole Castro I wonder if
does Senator Rubio also keep gold bars
and cash just because he's worried about
the authorities I I obviously that's BS
gold bar Bob learned everything he knows
from the big guy you nailed it about the
Foreign Relations Committee your own
Foreign Relations you have the power to
kind of green light or red light for an
aid so when there's a freeze on foreign
aid to a country you say you want me to
unfreeze that pay me the cash or even if
the money keeps flowing he said you know
what I did that that was me and so
that's how these guys get paid he
learned it under Joe and Joe did it the
same thing in Ukraine remember that one
billion uh you know what you're gonna
have to fire the prosecutor the funny
thing is this guy also got a prosecutor
in there to help him out he got the
Porsche you got the Mercedes Biden's had
diamonds this guy had gold bars they all
had dinners with the clients it's all
very similar except this guy's even
stupider than the bidens because the
bidens had plausible deniability what I
want to know is the Biden justice
department popped this guy a year ago so
he's walking around for a whole year
knowing that Joe Biden has him by the
gold bars what was Joe Biden squeezing
him for for an entire year well you go
back and you look at it this guy's been
a thorn in the side to Biden and Obama
for many many years he's been against
the Iran deal Biden's wearing to that he
doesn't want to open Cuba Biden wants it
open he's against the whole Venezuelan
amnesty deal so this guy's now gotten
out of the way so Joe Biden foreign
policy wise he's cleared the deck and he
can do what he wants
um Sandra what are your thoughts here he
thinks he's being targeted because he's
Latin American
um he does he's played the race card he
says he's been charged because he's a
Latino American those behind this
campaign and simply cannot accept the
first generation Latin American from
humble beginnings could rise to be a U.S
senator you know there's a lot of
Democrats who are now coming out right
Harold you've got John fetterman you've
got AOC they're all coming out saying he
should resign he got one thing right he
said these allegations leveled against
me are just that allegations and that is
true innocent until proven guilty but
there are very specific detailed
allegations so whether or not he'll be
exonerated obviously there are a lot of
people laughing at that the legal
experts are weighing in the Googling of
the gold bars while funny could be you
know he could have just been curious but
we could have helped him out with that
legal experts are saying that this is a
monster indictment it's very strong
concerning for Menendez another says
should be concerned right now about
these charges you know I think this just
highlights what judge said a second ago
like he's either he was really stupid to
do this after 2015 or just thinks he's
Above the Law and I think it's one
another one of those stories people at
home go really really and did he think
he was going to get away with it you
know Harold I was shocked what you said
in the Green Room you said why is it why
is it that Democrats always accuse Trump
and Republicans of what they're actually
doing themselves here's another example
of where they what they accuse others of
doing corruption is actually what
they're doing is this a form of
distraction is that a commercial where
they say let's go to the tape yes we
should go to the tape I I don't recall
it quite that way I'll say this judge I
agree with everything that's been said
around the table he's presumed innocent
until uh until proven otherwise if you
listen to what John fetterman said he
was the first center of the call from
him to resign he said he's entitled this
is what John fetterman said about
Senator Menendez he's entitled to the
presumption of innocence on our citizen
system but he is not entitled to
continue the world influence over
National policy especially given a
serious and specific specific nature of
the allegations and he said that wearing
pajama bottoms
uh you have Phil Murphy the governor of
New Jersey you have several members of
that delegation the one member of the
delegation I think some are waiting to
hear from is Senator Booker uh who's
been uh they have been great allies in
the Senate we'll see what happens there
legally um I agree with the judge some
of these things some of the facts here
very different than the first case that
Senator Menendez dealt with you may
recall he was accused of wielding
influence for a personal friend and they
apparently took trips together and he
got often on the hung jury this here
there's just more details their emails
their texts uh and again I I we all will
hear his defense it's when he when he's
able to do it but when the White House
today said this was a serious matter and
didn't want to respond to respond about
it I'm not I'm not convinced Jesse the
theory that you have it's your theory I
respect it I'm not sure that's the
theory that I think that the White House
wants him out of the way but but I do
believe that Senator Menendez he may be
at the height of unless he's able to
present more evidence judge in the
coming days to show that this stuff is
not true I don't imagine he's going to
gain more allies over the next few days
over the next few weeks he could
actually lose more apparently he's hired
Abby Lowell or maybe continued using
Albertville who's a good lawyer so we'll
all have to wait but he was he was uh he
was menendezvous
he was also Jared kushner's lawyer also
yeah everybody all right hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now